Anamika const is a candidate for new
york city public advocate and she joins
us to make you thanks a lot for coming
on high-tech are you doing great
so most but i'm a little bit confused so
mostly debates about climate change or
one person saying it's real or the other
ones like i don't have all the evidence
granted I grant everything you say about
climate change I'm just just for the
sake of this conversation that's a start
but if you really believe what you're
saying and if Bernie Sanders really
believes what he's saying
why is he flying a private planes I mean
this is sincere question so let's not
get distracted from the real issue here
not gonna let you off that easily why is
it not a real issue if climate change is
Katy Turner's told us it's really the
only issue that matters then why aren't
we living like it's the only issue that
matters down to the industry if the
industry wants to make planes that exist
off of renewable energy rather than than
oil and gas then we will all be able to
live on this planet it starts at the
industry level not the consumer you know
it's not it's not fair for someone who's
telling us the planets being destroyed
to live in a way that suggests that he
actually believes the planets being
destroyed so I don't I don't see I
really don't get it so if your outboard
you say nothing is more important than
climate change I'm a better person than
you are because I care more than you by
the way I've one of the largest houses
in Nashville and I fly private and I
take a suburban to the private Airport
to the FBO why should I be okay I'm
sincerely why does one individual
choices are not going to solve the
disaster that we are facing we already
have a migration issue we already have
flooding we already have heard news like
that have hit Puerto Rico have hit have
hit New Orleans have hit Florida and
have displaced so many working people
this is an industry change we have to
cap emissions globally of admissions the
key industries and policy then as
individual choices mean nothing okay
hold on first of all individual choices
always mean something I'm not a
libertarian I'm not living in a fantasy
world and we
life individual choices matter or else
what's the point of any of this okay so
it does start with liberals used to say
it starts with one person I guess they
don't anymore because they don't want to
be held to their own standards but the
solutions are always like ordinary
working people ought to pay higher gas
tax at all and actually we are against
that progressives versus the neoliberals
and neo-cons
progressives understand that this needs
to be a huge policy change to the place
where we are right now if we increase
the temperature one degree you and I
won't be living in DC in New York
anymore but we won't be this late no no
I want to see okay I want to talk about
the public policy solutions that will
flow from the predictions that you're
making is there any solution you've ever
heard of that doesn't increase the price
of energy I've never heard of one well
okay so if you're gonna be focused on
the price of energy we're not gonna have
to plan it in ten years the solutions a
solution would be a green new deal
moving to 100% renewable energy forcing
the companies that are jacking up the
prices on working people to actually
reduce their emissions so that working
people aren't displaced so working
people that are commercially damn
industry Vaseline water and the water is
not being privatized volume is not the
same as an argument
okay so just really simple question you
know my yours you don't want to do
Larrin right now let me let me just ask
you a really simple question would the
solutions that you're espousing now
would they raise the price of gasoline
for wage earners the one new deal I'm
actually actually pay the same price I
am against raising consumer prices that
is a neoliberal design I am a Democratic
Socialist I think we should pass
policies and actually make rich people
millionaires and billionaires and
corporations pay taxes that's the
problem no one at the top is paying
taxes and the Berkshire consumer which
you would allow private planes to fly I
guess right
I think please have an obligation to
change their standards that is what
policy is all about should we get
Plains solar pipe repair I mean I don't
know how that would function but I think
that there are other addition forms of
energy really quick just for fun name a
renewable energy source that can power
our plane well there's there's I mean we
see with cars we know I'm serious
I mean there are do you know what a
Prius is and a Tesla is you could do
that on airplanes an electric airplane a
big lexically I mean I have no engineer
but I have heard of electric cars and
airplanes and other forms of electric
solution I mean there's also solar
generated so that the electricity that
you're charging with his shoulders
energy we're back to the so more weight
generate these sites that text me a
picture if you find one on the Internet
Mickey thank you very much great to
solve this problem you can't live it
another planet good to see you